TRACKS FOR THE WEST COAST, ALEX
>> Craig: IT'S GOING TO BE
INTERESTING HOW HE RECOVERS
AFTER BEING ON COVID PROTOCOL, E
SLAPSHOT BY THE BIG FELLA AND A
WE TOLD YOU, THE SECOND GAME
FOR CROSBY, THIS ONE IS BY RUSTE
NEUTRAL ZONE, THEN RIGHT THERET,
MAGNIFICENT STOPE LAST OPPORTUN
PENGUINS BACK IN THIS HOCKEY
GAME.
IT NOW HATHAWAY IS
RUNNING AWAY WITH GOAL
GREAT SAVET IN
THE BACKHANDER AS HE WAS THE. N
GOAL AMOUNT, JUS
FINDING DANIEL SPRONG. BEAUTIFU.
SHEARY FOR THE GOOD GUYS
STAYING UP LATE WITH YOU IN THE
WEEK AHEAD, WASHINGTON WITH
GAMES AT
>> Joe: YOU AND EVERYONE. RST LY
RODRIGUEZ, A FEW MOMENTS AGO
BUT THIS ONE GRE, A
BACKHAND, OPENS UP